a pesar de la indignación en las calles
contra la controvertida reforma de las
pensiones
el gobierno francés no quiere retrasar
su aprobación tras presentar el proyecto
el lunes se espera que la nueva ley esté
en la asamblea nacional a finales de mes
donde se someterá a debate creo que es
momento de avanzar y comprometernos para
que el gobierno pueda hacer su trabajo
en la asamblea nacional con serenidad y
ganas de convencer
para ayudar al país a avanzar la reforma
del presidente pretende aumentar la edad
de jubilación en Francia de 62 a 64 años
para que los trabajadores cobren su
pensión íntegra también deberán haber
cotizado durante 43 años ya que el
gobierno pretende adelantar de 2035 a
2027 la Norma que exige 43 años de
ahorro en un plan de pensiones el
gobierno también ha anunciado que
reevaluará el salario mínimo de
jubilación y reducirá la brecha de
retribución de las pensiones entre
hombres y mujeres teniendo en cuenta
otros factores como el permiso parental
a pesar de ello la mayoría de los
partidos de la oposición Están en contra
rotundamente a esta reforma los
sindicatos y los políticos de izquierda
han hecho un llamado para que continúen
las huelgas y las protestas
lideraremos la lucha el clima político
para una retirada es la movilización
Popular nosotros haremos el trabajo pero
es sobre todo el pueblo El que debe
levantarse pueden ser arrogantes que
verse Intocables pero cuando el pueblo
se levanta
retrocede
aunque se esperan más movilizaciones
para el 31 de enero el gobierno Busca
adherirse a su plan y aplicar la reforma
a finales de marzo